well the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
going crazy today released fans of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are going
crazy today that's right no button up
why because if Marvel's gonna flip their
[ __ ] up on a test so am I at least for
this video I'm lazy that's why there's
been a really strong rumor lately that
Captain America 3 is going to be Civil
War it's pretty much Iron Man and
Captain America clashing and now Variety
reported on us so I guess we all have to
take it as was probably going to happen
those of you don't know what variety is
per the people who live in Hollywood and
people in entertainment in general
variety is the magazine equivalent to
those two stone tablets that Moses
walked down the mountain with those 10
suggestions written on them if they
report on something like this take the
heart that is looking pretty good it's
gonna happen Civil War is huge of comic
book fans that I know and nerd friends
that I have they were talking about
civil war when Nick Fury was at the end
of Iron Man gone I'm here to talk about
the Avengers initiative people you know
this means one day civil war so one
Civil War the government's like okay we
have a superhero Registration Act
superheroes after register and we're
gonna keep tabs on them and after that
it creates a divide among heroes on this
side people who agree with that on the
other side people who are like that's
unconstitutional that is [ __ ] think
of it as meeting registration in x-men
only very much identical to that and
heading up the side this like yes
government you are right for doing that
we need to keep tabs on those people is
Iron Man Tony Stark and heading up the
other side that's like no that's
unconstitutional that is wrong enter
Steve Rogers Captain America which I
love that promise do those two argue
about everything like seriously they'll
be like no citizen diet dr. pepper does
not taste more like regular dr. pepper
yeah only actually it does and then
they'll just argue about it for like
thirty seven minutes so take something
monumental like this superhero
registration and they're they're gonna
fight about it and this could be really
cool allegedly because it's not actually
confirmed in which means by the time I
upload this it's going to be confirmed
so I have to put an annotation on this
video's gonna irritate me turn on your
annotation and on everyone's mind it was
always like all right everything leads
up to the Avengers and the Avengers
movies are huge and we're going to have
age of Ultron for Avengers 2 and then
Avengers 3 is going to be Fano so now
they're gonna have Civil War but where
it's gonna start in Captain America 3
and carry over to Avengers 3 or 4 after
cap 2 you know they were like all right
we need a minute cap 3 awesome because
apparently Captain America can be
awesome hey everyone we can do Civil War
Captain America 3 now it doesn't have to
be Avengers 4 this means the Captain
America movies are officially the
coolest movies in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe yeah it'll be a little
different because people know who all
the Avengers identities are like Daisy
Future Passed or any huge arc you're
gonna have to tweak it to accommodate
the fact that it's a movie
can have it just be like the
government's like oh hey your are
[ __ ] you work for us now and then the
divide happens was like no or yes I
guess we'll fight each other I feel like
Tony Stark creating Ultron's gonna play
a huge factor into that I mean
theorizing here nothing's in stone but
here we go
this is why we do this I've seen it in
the comments section people like why are
you talking about something like why
would you waste your time doing a video
talking about this cuz I'm a fan of
movies and it's fun but I like
theorizing so theory for me would be
that Tony Stark creates Ultron that
creates a shitstorm in the government's
like you know what we need to contain
these people cuz that's Tony Stark's
superpower his superpower is his brain
his genius the fact that he created an
Iron Man suit and a suit that flies
around it has missiles and [ __ ] built
into it a whole fancy-schmancy tech [ __ ]
that's all a byproduct of his superpower
which is his genius so the government's
like people like that need to be
contained man they need to be controlled
I'm sure Tony Stark's like yeah I need
to pay for that because I agree with you
guys people like me should be controlled
I have proven that we are a problem so
his ambition drives him to create Ultron
which makes him a problem and then his
guilt drives him to support the
government and that whole superhero
Registration Act bang Tony Stark does
not have the easy life in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the fact is I'm
looking forward to seeing this though
you saw in the last Avengers movie how
all these strong personalities get in a
room they start arguing about [ __ ] it's
not gonna be all sunshine and rainbows
man so I'm looking forward to something
that just divides them down the middle
is not a lot of love left in the
Avengers that's what happens when you
try to force friendships I'm looking
forward to a Marvel movie where one of
the Marvel heroes is actually one of the
Marvel villains it's Tony Stark it's
Iron Man we've loved him from the
beginning I think it would be great if
the one that started the Cinematic
Universe off the one who kicked it off
is actually the villain and furthermore
it'd be great if you see his point of
view but if he's like this is why I'm
doing this this is why I support this
and the audience could be like oh [ __ ]
yeah I agree with you yeah that Ultron
thing that was a bad move and I'd
probably be doing exactly what you're
doing right now if I were you
I think Captain America's like no this
is why it's wrong the audience could be
like yeah I agree with him - that's toda
[ __ ] I'm conflicted gotta mess with the
audience's mind on this [ __ ] so Iron Man
in Captain America 3 as the villain for
Civil War allegedly but not confirmed
yet are you liking that what would you
like to see in it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you